uh it's inspiring to see all you
ambitious mind um Minds pushing for what
really can be um Kazar rascom is an
impact driven Town
developer um our group delivered 40,000
homes uh in government programs um in uh
Urban expansions integrated towns uh
we're part of the sis family uh orascom
con at uh we believe that all families
should have the opportunity to own a
home with dignity and a real asset to
pass on to their children we also
believe that um cities are not just
engines of growth they should be um
systems for well-being and ultimately
happiness three very different examples
uh this is Haram City 400 hectares 20 km
west of Cairo uh 12,000 affordable homes
built 40,000 residents Center left uh an
urban uh center right a very vibrant
downtown four schools retail Clinic
religious and sports
facilities um unit sizes between 38 to
60 square meters selling price is
between 25 to 40,000 per home uh 50
megawatt station uh more green areas
than even luxury developments and um we
create jobs in textile and uh recycling
companies the s's family foundations
also accompany our projects and in here
400 Street children um uh are safely
housed and uh educated the other town
eluna uh for
perspective this is 4 by 9 kilm for
perspective that's um everything in
Manhattan below 110th Street so all of
Central Park uh Upper West upper east
Midtown All the Way South uh half is
developed and uh you know conceived by
my chairman samas you see how we brought
the sea into the the desert um 25,000
permanent residents uh three marinas
4,000 Villas and apartments 2,000
affordable homes for low-income families
uh 400 retail outlets 100 plus
restaurants uh Campus of the Technical
University of Berlin uh four primary and
high schools uh a hotel school and even
a branch of the Library of
Alexandria uh we got 20 hotels here uh
3,000 rooms Hospital airport solar power
plant and eluna won the United Nations
uh Global green award uh now radically
different different uh a passion project
our philanthropic arm the Baraka slum in
dhar Sagal uh 1,600 people in absolute
uh hardship
but Urban slums often sit on incredibly
valuable land and so we can eradicate
slums uh at final net cost zero
how on 2third of the land we built free
Apartments for the slum residents uh
along with a school a kindergarten
vocational training uh and and shops for
them to work in and no longer a slum the
remaining freed up onethird of land uh
skyrockets in value and there we build
and sell apartments and the profit
recovers the 6.5 million that my
chairman invested as a bridge final net
cost zero and so now you do that again
with the same money and ideally uh you
raise funds to replicate the model uh
1,600 people live in their new homes now
what thank you thank
you uh what next and this is where all
of you come in right the Dakar Peninsula
4 million people pushing towards our
land in red 200 hectares 3 km Coastline
1 kilm Lake uh Pine Forest Dunes this is
real
this is now this is ready and a white
canvas for your companies and for your
support and for your ideas so let's join
forces uh to break with everything all
the old everything right so you want to
you want to build a better society and
correct the wrong then let's find the
best people out there let's find the
most brilliant ones in in in water in
power in sewage in waste and education
and in mobility and so um yeah let's go
and build a town and we start now the
second I get off the stage here I'm
taking names who's in thank
you